let's figure out where seven thirds
would go on this number line right over
here and the first thing i want to make
sure is that we know what the units of
this number line are so we starting with
zero we have one slash another slash a
third slash and then that's three so the
slashes must represent
what must represent one so this must be
one this must be two and then this is
three and then going in the left
direction this must be negative one this
must be negative two and then they
already mark it for us that is negative
three so the each slash here represents
exactly one unit so to think about where
seven thirds goes i like to think of it
as a mixed so right now it's an improper
fraction i'd like to rewrite it as a
mixed number so 7 over 3 that's the same
thing as 3 divided into seven
three goes into seven
two times two times three is six your
remainder is one so this is the same
thing so seven over three is the same
thing as seven divided by three is the
same thing as seven divided by three
which is the same thing as two
you it's you three goes into seven two
times and then you have a remainder of
one so it's two and one
two and one thirds this one
is this one right over here this third
is this three right over there and then
this two
is this two right over here so seven
thirds is the same thing as two and one
third so where would i plot two and one
third so this is one this is two and
then it's going to be one more third so
if i split this into thirds one two and
then three two and one thirds is going
to sit is going to sit right
over there